Yes, it's very, very unpleasant, it's
incomprehensible, tell me it's strange,
bite me, the
parents of the college know, and I
have to let you know by the way.The
college is going on lockdown now.What is the
lockdown?
Recently, there has been a series of incidents where students have been harmed in a row right next to the college, and for
safety reasons, we will be
shutting down the school for a while.We have heard about this and it is
urgent, so
we will notify all parents in due course.  My teeth are sharp, my
ears are big,
my beard is trembling, and I can see your eyes too. I
know you're there, I can
hear you, I can see you.
Good luck,
timing.  It's too soon. Everyone was pissed.
I mean, I've
never heard of them obeying anyone but Kett, but that does
n't mean they obey. We're equals.